afd-chef Tino krupala vergangenen
Samstag in Krefeld
copala und seine Partei ziehen ganz
eigene Schlüsse aus dem russischen
Angriffskrieg die AFD steht für eine
neutrale Haltung Deutschlands im
ukrainekrieg für ein Stopp der
Waffenlieferung und der Aufhebung der
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland laut einer
aktuellen Umfrage Glauben
42,5% der afd-anhänger die NATO und die
USA sein die Hauptschuldigen am Ukraine
Krieg nicht etwa Putin das ist fremder
Krieg auf unserem Boden ausgeführt wird
Mozart gegen Amerika ich meine Mutter
sich gut in gesprächsbereit hält und
erklärt sollten wir diese Chance nutzen
auch im Bundestag nimmt copala den
Aggressor Putin in Schutz es darf in
diesen Tagen aber nicht unser Ziel sein
den einen Schuldigen auszumachen AFD
intern schreibt propala wir sind keine
Pazifisten sondern Patrioten das
Gegenteil von patriotisch ist aber sein
Land in einen fremden Krieg zu stürzen
seine Waffen einer fremden Armee
auszuhändigen also dass diese Ukraine
uns nun fremder oder fremd sein soll im
Kontrast zu einem Russland das
autokratisch ist das ist in der Tat
bemerkenswert das heißt die AFD macht
sich im Grunde genommen Liebkind oder
setzt sich in eine Allianz mit dem
Aggressor der nicht nur die Ukraine von
der Landkarte tilgen will sondern auch
die europäische Friedensordnung aus den
Angel heben will wir wollen koopala zu
seiner russlandfreundlichen Haltung
befragen
der afd-chef lehnt ein Interview ab
dabei hat ein bundestagsmitarbeiter des
Parteichefs auf telegram das z-zeichen
gezeigt dass die russischen Panzer
tragen co-palas Mitarbeiter nennt sich
Usbekistan mg
nachfrageversuch bei copala hören sie
mich irgendwie schwersprecher spanisch
kroatisch oder was wenn ich sage nein
dann heißt es nein Punkt Ende danke die
afd-bundestagsfraktion hat einen
Arbeitskreis Außenpolitik dominiert von
Russland Freunden wie propala
der afd-arbeitskreis schreibt in einem
internen Papier nach Kriegsbeginn die
Bundesregierung muss im Sinne der
unteilbaren Sicherheit auf eine
gemeinsame europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur hinwirken und die
legitimen russischen
sicherheitsinteressens berücksichtigen
wenn die AFD von legitim
Sicherheitsinteressen Russland spricht
dann hat sie offensichtlich die im Auge
die Putin auch für die legitimen hält
denn um was anderes kann es nicht gehen
denn darum dreht sich ja der Krieg nur
diese sogenannten legitimen
Sicherheitsinteressen sind nichts
anderes als geschichtslegitimierte
imperiale Bestrebungen Souveränität
Staaten die auf der Basis des
Völkerrechts auf der Basis
völkerrechtlicher Verträge entstanden
sind sozusagen von der Landkarte zu
schieben die Ukraine als Opfer des
russischen Angriffs kommen in den
afd-papieren so gut wie nicht vor
auch der afd-abgeordnete Eugen Schmidt
kommt aus Nordrhein-Westfalen Schmidt
ist Vorsitzender der Russlanddeutschen
für die AFD in Kasachstan geboren
erhielt er als Spätaussiedler 1999 die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
kurz vor Kriegsbeginn betont Schmidt die
Friedfertigkeit Russlands
wollen die Russen Krieg sicher nicht
nachkriegsbeginn verbreitet Schmidt
russische Propaganda der Westen übergeht
seit langem russische
Sicherheitsinteressen und hat das Leid
der Menschen im Donbass ignoriert
Eugen Schmidt reiste 2009 in seiner alte
Heimat Kasachstan die
einreisebestätigung zeigt erstaunliches
Schmidt weist sich damals als russischer
Staatsbürger aus mit einem Pass der bis
2010 gültig war aus afd-kreisen heißt es
Schmidt sei bis heute deutscher und
russischer Staatsbürger ob das stimmt
Schmidt äußert sich dazu nicht
fest steht Schmidt war im April im
Düsseldorfer Landtag dabei als ein AFD
Russlanddeutscher vor Parteifreunden
gegen ukrainische Flüchtlinge hetzte
ukrainische Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland
kommen ist seine Gefahr für uns
russlanddeutsch für unsere Frauen für
unsere Kinder die fangen jetzt schon an
uns zu terrorisieren gegen Eugen Walter
läuft ein Parteiausschlussverfahren
trotzdem ist dabei co-palas Kundgebung
dabei doch für einige in der Partei ist
grupalas pro Putin Kurs schuld daran
dass die AFD aus dem Landtag in
Schleswig-Holstein hinausgeflogen ist
wenn man sich anschauen wer diese Wahlen
gewonnen hat haben wir die Wahl Gewinner
waren dass man diejenigen die
vorangegangen sind und haben gesagt wir
machen das jetzt wir unterstützen die
Ukraine Selbstbestimmung und diejenigen
die in der Frage gezaubert haben die
sind als Wahl Verlierer eigentlich vom
Tisch gegangen ist Kraft ist einer von
vier afd-abgeordneten die für
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
stimmten gegen die Parteilinie auch
Roger beckamp unterstützt die Ukraine
nicht Russland
insofern ist das jetzt auch ein
patriotischer Abwehrkampf gegen so eine
imperiale Macht gegen einen einen Staat
der eben schon mal früher in Form eines
Sowjet Reiches und davor als Zarenreich
dieses Land
einverleibt hatte
[Musik]
vor der entscheidenden Landtagswahl in
NRW ist die AFD gespalten für oder gegen
Putin